this movie starts off with 40 seconds of
shots of feet or more specifically shoes
also how did Jason get here we're not at
Camp Crystal Lake
so did he take a plane bus the deaning
money or was he a winner of some sort of
make-a-wish event was wearing a sack on
his head the whole time or D just
walking around showing his garbage pail
kid face also how does he even know
where Alice lips was able to sweet-talk
a public records officer geez I guess
Jason was just standing right next to a
little kid
his mom was more concerned about him
getting wet than getting killed plus we
never hear about this kid again probably
because he was killed by Pennywise and
not Jason but what's the point of him
being here a Nightmare on Elm Street on
Friday the 13th did you know that a
young boy dropped movie that is 86
minutes Steel's about half of its run
time from the first movie it's while
watching this fight again and getting an
unexpected boner that I pause to reflect
what makes a great movie and I'm pretty
sure not rehashing another movie for
long stretches is one of the criteria I
mean this isn't just a simple reminder
this is the whole fight the ending in
the first film never makes clear whether
alice is attacked by Jason was a dream
or not which is fine but showing it here
makes it seem like we're supposed to
think maybe it actually happened this is
weird because Jason is a clearly grown
adult in this film and then we find out
she died two months after this also if
this did happen wouldn't that make Jason
some sort of ghost he looks like he's
been in that water for a long time and
he appears to be cut up or something a
lot he just drowned but whatever if he's
a ghost then the rest of this movie
really makes no sense furthermore I'll
just say what the first movies
filmmakers said about this movie if
Jason was indeed alive this whole time
why didn't he tell his mom before she
went out in that murderous rampage or is
this movie saying that her murders made
him rise from the dead man we didn't
find any boy
that's the moment we wake up startled I
would think he would wake up like that
after the attack but I guess we had to
see that final moment of her in the
hospital to make this movie even more
confusing also alice's dreams are up she
has dreams about things that actually
happen and with better recall than an
actual memory also this is a nearly
three-minute unbroken shot which would
be awesome if it wasn't simply Alice
going to the bathroom talking to her
mother and taking a shower when they
decided to do an unbroken shot they went
with the most mundane part of the movie
also this house appears to be pretty
small
where the could Jason possibly be hiding
Friday to was using the same POV shots
from the first film in a scene where
there doesn't need to be a POV shot if
Jason is in front of her here then I'm
pretty sure she's not going to keep
casually talking to her mom after that
crazy one take where so much happened
the movie does another 90 second one
tape where even more happens sorry I
think I got so sarcastic with this
comment that I don't even know what
comparative adjectives I'm supposed to
use what exactly startled Alice that
could have been a wrong number and why
wasn't the door locked also who exactly
does she think is coming after her she
chopped mrs. Voorhees head clean off and
was told that there was no one in the
lake but she sure is walking around her
house like she knows she's about to get
stabbed in the head by the hell is this
taking so long you've seen every part of
this house so many times I know more
about it than my own yep might as well
get a cat scare in there we've only got
an hour and change left in the movie
let's just keep patting any other
cliches out that window maybe a trash
can that needs to fall over also this is
a woman who was torn psychologically by
the events of the first movie so either
she keeps a window open which is
unbelievable or she's not the least bit
surprised or scared by a window being
open also back to the cat because this
is some bullshit you're telling me this
cat got so scared it leapt through the
entire windowsill from the ground so let
me get this straight
Jason must have gotten here while Alice
was having incredibly accurate dreams
about him put a head in the fridge
waited for her to wake up talk to her
mom take a shower before finally killing
her I guess he also waited for her to
see the head or else he would have had
to wait longer under the table with the
pantry or the fourth dimension where he
came from gotta hand it to Jason even
though he's a mass killer he's polite
and takes the tea off the stove when
it's ready you gotta love the opening
credits that credit the actress whose
character just died and built here with
some other asshole in the movie sorry
Adrian your role in the first movie and
death in the second movie is worth
exactly one co-credit
apparently audiences love this awful
character from the first movie and
demanded that he returned also
does anyone else think they should have
made Ralph the killer in this film we
always done more about him than we do
Jason okay if you needed to use the
phone why didn't you just perk by the
phone booth yeah okay okay this was the
same problem from the first movie people
coming out to this town with no idea of
where to go how does this guy not
already have directions to the place if
he knew how to get to the town it's also
his truck and get towed I guess
[Music]
how does Ralph even know that Jeff and
Sandra are there to go to the camp so
this asshole played a prank on his
buddies but how did he know they would
stop in front of the package store and
run to a phone booth to call it or was
this how they planned it hey guys when
you get to town be sure to stop and call
me then I'll give you extra directions
talk talk jokes about old times bla bla
seriously does anything happen in these
movies before the 45 minute mark maybe a
tree there's a few those surrounding you
know did Jason know there would be
people coming out to the lake today does
he tap phones
I didn't Jason just killed him here he
seems to be building suspense for the
unseen audience rather than for his
raging killing boner scenes like this
and crazy Ralph's phone booth runnin
makes me think they were still going for
the same murder mystery angle they used
in the first one but we know it's Jason
they don't even hide it in the trailer
for the film so I'm not sure why any of
this red herring bullshit was needed
it's like trying to paint Andy as the
killer in the first child's play it's
great to have you all here at a new
counselor training center wait a minute
so why did Jason single out Jeff Ted and
Sandra on the way up here you mean the
other camp counselors got to drive on
the road without a tree branch blocking
their way but those guys are somehow
special also because a camp counselor
training center in my entire life I'm
glad that the movie had time to go
through all the bull about Jenny being
late I'm sure her lateness will affect
the entire movie somehow phone says this
despite ginnis car being the only one
visible in this area among other things
this is bear country
and contrary to what everybody here is
bears are dangerous do you mean there
was some sort of misinformation back in
1981 about bears
well Smokey the Bear is such an icon
that people thought he spoke for all
bears even though he was just a dude in
a costume also bears are mentioned so
many times in these Friday the 13th
movies it's a real shame that we never
get a good bear scare
clean during your menstrual cycle things
that would never be said in a movie made
past 1989 for 100 Alex use a little that
child psychology majoring in Paul's
subtle foreshadowing line for shadows so
hard that I went blind looking directly
at it without special glasses try what
did you do all you did was look at the
engine you didn't do anything you don't
even have any tools in your hands I want
to scare anyone I'm gonna give it to you
straight about Jason even though he's
not currently connected to any murderers
but his mother sure is because his body
was never recovered from the lake after
he drowned but that was 20 years ago so
he's probably not a threat anyway back
to his mom but of course she's a goddamn
liar because she was never in any
position to seal in fact now that I
think about it why did she assume that
was Jason out there nothing supernatural
happened in the first movie until that
very moment so the idea of a dead kid
coming out of the water to drown her
would have been far-fetched even after
what she experienced I'm really fuckin a
dead
[Applause]
check look I'm not expecting this dill
weed who trains camp counselors to be
Bobby Fischer but for fuck's sake how
does he miss that Ginny's queen is in
the direct path of his checking Knight
that's racist
indeed it is checkmate I'd like to know
how the kiss King got halfway up the
board and he never used his rooks is
there any way Paul gets into the cabin
while Ginny was right at the door sure
her back was turned but Paul's chess
game makes me believe he wouldn't be the
best at sneaking into a cabin without
making noise and he wouldn't be able to
anticipate Ginny looking in only one
direction we never find out what Ginny
needs to tilt it but I swear to god
there was a pregnancy subplot in this
movie talk about menstrual cycles
lectures about being laid the maternal
sympathy Ginny shows toward Jason later
or getting pissed at Paul for not
understanding that dynamic but we never
hear about this again where the hell is
Jason he's either hanging upside down
from what looks like a pretty small tree
or he's 9 feet tall it's more if Jason's
intent was to kill Paul or Ginny tonight
he didn't go through with it so he must
have known crazy Ralph would be peeping
by the tree or else this tree killing
makes no sense
dead dog hot dog Terry appears to be
looking directly at whoever is looking
at her so how does she not see them I
just store my chainsaw here in the linen
closet
what are you kids doing out here this
dedicated cop somehow walk through the
leaves without making one fucking sound
he's gonna have to keep your people away
from that place hopes it's condemned
next time I catch anybody over there
we'd have to run them in why is Camp
Crystal Lake so off limits to the point
that there's a cop or roving the streets
looking for trespassers giving warnings
yes mrs. Voorhees killed a lot of people
there but nothing has happened for five
years it's almost like the cops know
that Jason is a thing when nobody knows
that Jason is a thing five years this
guy's been patrolling these woods and
this is the first time he's ever seen a
six-foot-tall kill happy Psychopaths
running around I guess Jason was
pupating and it well concealed cocoon
for five years and that's after the 20
years living like the Loch Ness monster
and Camp Crystal it a full minute of
running so did no one know this place
existed also it's been five years and
Jason hasn't killed anyone there haven't
been some curious hikers well at least
we know where Jason Takes of glad this
movie chooses to answer the really
important questions also why doesn't the
sheriff at least have his gun pulled at
this point between this and scream - I'm
starting to think that all the slashers
are smart enough to go to towns where
the dumbest cops ever employed okay you
only have two cars did everyone get
there this nipples girl nipples doesn't
nipples seem nipples - nipples worried
nipples about nipples her nipples dog
nipples being nipples gone nipples for
nipple hours I guess cleaning up meant
grabbing the flag but not picking up any
other dishes and food left on the tables
way to follow Paul's strict rules on
bear prevention looks like teri went to
the nicolas cage in Wicker Man School of
thinking every little noise is whoever
you're looking for well my dog has been
missing for several hours so I guess
it's time to skinny dip in the lake
looking for something I'm going to sin
1981 for this being acceptable behavior
in a movie I guess we can trace this
kind of thing back to Animal House
really but you 1981 this is where we
keep the dirty towels the woodland fairy
puts it in the washer and the garden
gnomes dry it with their peppermint
schnapps breath there's a fully stocked
kitchen just a few feet away teri
instead goes to a room to look for a
night
it only takes 50 minutes for our first
camp counselor mm I mean camp counselor
and training - doc god damn I hate this
dude end of sin you know - what kids
that bowling today it's weird to me that
tip refers to them as two of our kids
aren't Sondra and Jeff his friends
they're the ones who called him at the
beginning of the movie and they drove
together to the campsite so isn't it
weird you're referring to them as if
they're your employee
stop holding today was five years ago
some girl panics and fold out of a canoe
and a bunch of people were killed by
some deranged mother but you know
semantics you don't see this mother get
killed and all just because she loved it
wait isn't that what her revenge is all
about her sense a loss wow Ginny is 100%
correct there's nothing in this world
that should make this sound like
rational thought
in one breath Ginny says Jason saw his
mother get killed because she was mad
that he died think about that for a
second I thought they went to go for ten
minutes ago what took them so long three
goals you're gonna lose you ham it seems
like a very random thing to have been
told before where did that car come from
Paul specifically said they only had two
cars okay
where the fuck was Jason there were
shots of mark from the front and there
was no one behind him for whatever
reason Jason decides to bury his machete
into marks skull and never tries to get
it back but this really illustrates is
this camps dire need to put in
wheelchair ramps ah yes Jason knew he
wouldn't need the machete anymore
because he knew there was a spear he
could use later also do we really need
these establishing shots of Jason
walking into the cabin and going up the
stairs I can totally buy that Jason
knows how to use stairs to get to Jeff
and Sondra also am I the only one that
thinks that Ted's mask would be way
creepier in future installments than the
hockey mask holy how awesome is the
spear it went through two bodies a
mattress and maybe even a box spring you
mean King Ted stays behind and gets to
survive this movie
cuz this scene what the fuck okay so
Vicky is still alive which is cool but
I'm wondering why Jason sat here looking
at her but decided now I'll kill mark
first I think it's possible we've seen
more people walk up these stairs than
we've seen get killed don't mind me guys
we all have urges I'm just looking for
the guy who was supposed to do me if
you're naked that's cool nothing I
haven't seen before
great jump scared but what's Jason just
lying there the whole time waiting for
someone to come check on Jeff and Sandra
and he just assumed they wouldn't see
Jeff propped up by the wall also is
there any reason why she isn't running
the hell out of there right now while
Jason takes ten years to kill Vicky and
she does nothing to get away from him
I'd like Jason to explain why he holds
knives and machetes with the opposite
end up I guess this is supposed to be
scarier but this is supposedly the guy
who takes Manhattan later I don't think
Manhattan socialite it's cotton to this
kind of thing this is a joke I mean I
told the mold bears no menstral cycles
thing kitchen lights still on must must
be the main fuse again and the bed full
of blood that's probably a circuit
breaker also if the main fuse is out
then why is the kitchen lights still on
[Applause]
Jason was a mastermind until this very
moment this is a guy who can predict
everyone's movements and kill like no
one else but in this scene he makes a
lame attempt to jump out of the shadows
and totally whip some killing Paul
[Music]
No watch your boyfriend wrestle with a
psychopath expert but wouldn't Jenny be
doing more more than just saying palm
very calmly while he fights for his life
sure we were given some foreshadowing of
this event but that doesn't make it any
less of a car won't start in a horror
movie cliche also she should do what
Paul did and stare at the engine for two
seconds because sometimes all the car
needs is a steely gaze first off Jason
slams his pitchfork into the middle of
the car roof a location where no driver
has ever sat in the history of cars
second off why did he even bother with
this couldn't he just do this through
the window and third off this reminds me
he had a perfectly good spear a minute
ago he obviously removed the spear from
the bed and the two bodies he stabbed so
where did that weapon go
jeanny lightly kicks Jason and he goes
sprawling and he's incapacitated until
she can escape instead of doing any more
running ginnis Brett idea is to wait
until Jason is again within kicking
distance to do the things she should
have been doing anyway the rat from
Mission Impossible and The Departed
makes a cameo here once again giving
zero about how ridiculous his appearance
at this very moment is wait a minute I
sense P behind me
Jason somehow stood on this chair
holding a pitchfork and genie didn't
hear it given that the chair breaks this
easily there's no way to in creak like a
motherfucker when he stood upon it and
man he really could have used that bed
stabbing spear I'm in love of that spear
this is why you keep your chains on the
linen closet as this movie expertly
showed us earlier you never know when
you'll need it around the house
this is a great final girl sequence I
almost want to remove one sin then there
was that whole urine thing that just
happened and I can't get past it genie
could have run I don't know how many
directions in the woods and she still
ends up at the shack also does this look
like a place anyone would live that
would in any way be remotely helpful
mommy is pleased this works but if this
is all it took for Jason to figure out
that Jinny was not his dead mom
reincarnated then I have trouble
believing why he fell for this ruse in
the first place this is Paul ex machina
so sure we'll sin that but did Jason
just knock Paul unconscious during the
fight and leave that it's not Jason's MO
but sure works out for the movie sick
it is said that from this one scene Zack
Snyder was born I'll be back but don't
let them ever put me in space Paul
enjoys kicking a man while he's down did
they even need to open the store if it
really is Jason can't let him try to get
through the door you have weapons to
kill him if necessary so why facilitate
his injury the muffin buried in the pet
cemetery or do you mean to tell me that
a dog that looked exactly like muffin
got killed when we saw that awful dog
corpse earlier also it's good to see
muffin alive that other dog funny Jason
without his mask looks exactly like
Michael Myers
that's so weird so which part of that
was a dream and which part wasn't are
Paul and muffin dead did Jenny even
survive someone gonna make me watch part
three so many questions and so many
answers I don't care about
you're looking at your pointless you
looking at your things you're thinking
to yourself I don't know what to do man
I don't know how to kill the bunny with
this you don't know how to kill the
bunny ever since cinemasins began the
most requested thing has been TV since
and now it's a reality click the link in
the description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
be afraid be very afraid I'll be right
back I'll be right back
where's my penis where's my penis and
that boy wants me
[Music]